so I'm um I'm gonna have a go at this
okay now I I couldn't do counted here
it's a bit hard for you guys to see so I
have um I have imaginary encounters now
before I start to play with these let's
just make sure we understand what the
question is right they say is it
possible can you place several and they
say several which means that how many is
part of the question can you place
several these honor they say on a plane
right on a flat plane 4 that means
missed a key that's what it implies such
that what's the condition that you're
aiming for what's the condition so that
every single counter coin whatever is
touching exactly three other ones so
that means not two not four not six
exactly through okay now my first
question is you know coming back to when
it said several right what's the minimum
number of coins that can actually
whether or not this there's a solution
to this or not
what's the nil no acquaintance has a
shot like a vague sort of possibility of
getting a solution
hmm so let's think about this for a
second one coin can one coin do it and
clearly answer is no because there are
no other coins for it to touch that
makes sense doesn't it okay now when you
add in a second coin you're still in
trouble because they're each touching
one but you need to get to three okay
now once I add in a third coin well
you've got a single coin that touches
too is there any way I can have any of
these coins like I could shuffle this
around I could I can move it over here
is there any coin that can touch the
three other coins and the answer is no
because for each coin there are no three
other coins that exist does that make
sense there's only two are the coins so
therefore I need a minimum the absolute
minimum that can even have a shot at
working is four so see this setup right
now you've got a single coin that
satisfies the condition that you wanted
right
is going here that one's touching three
but none of the others do okay
can't let me do this American I shuffle
this about and make this better
can I do better than one coin satisfying
the condition I'm Arthur I saw I saw
some of you who drive with foreign
you've got something better than this so
what if you have okay hold on before you
go on let's um let's put some names on
these right so as a mathematical
principle well when we struggle we're
like how do we talk about these things
you know that one over there with the
with the stuff and the other things when
you don't have labels for things you
can't describe things in a um an
accurate way so let's number them shall
we so let's call these 1 2 3 & 4 so
which one you talking about
you see how quickly having some language
here and some labels help us right
because now I know exactly where fo I
want me to put it I'm going to put it
over here okay so is this an improvement
it is it's objectively an improvement
because with the same number of coins
this guy is touching three coins and so
is this one yeah so far so good but then
you've got two and four and they're kind
of just sort of stuck there right and I
hope you realize you encountered this
problem you're like it's always the ends
the ends are always the problem because
we're going to turn off my internet
because I keep getting emails because if
you put a coin on the end like this what
have we done have we improved this
situation well it depends how you define
improves doesn't it you sort of improved
it because look at number four look at
four four is good yeah but when you have
a look at the new one that I've added
five is worse off than all the other
ones is only touching one okay now you
can try and put five in another position
to change this like where can I put five
reposition it so that it would touch
more points because only touching one
right now I could move five so it's
still touching four but I could swivel
it around so it's
pew so now five is touching two coins
but what have I done
yeah one is no longer satisfying my
condition right one is now touching four
coins so I'm in trouble okay so let's
rewind a little bit here we go
so this shape here seems like it will be
useful okay except for its ends now I
saw I think Jasmine's at you who had the
suggestion of saying well what if I just
take this whole thing right and just do
it again right because now can you see
one and three well let's let's give a
different name shall we let's call these
guys a 1 a 2 a 3 a 4 we'll call these B
1 B 2 B 3 B 4 because they want to be
three aren't exactly the same
configuration is a 1 and a 3 you know
that they work yeah
does that make sense and simultaneously
you've been printing this situation
right because look at the orphan over
here a 4 he's okay isn't he and so's b2
they're both good except we still have
this problem what's the what keeps on
being the problem it's always the end
the ends are always the issue if only we
had some kind of shape because
unfortunately if I do this or what a
third time right I still have the same
problem right if only I had some kind of
shape which would not have this problem
that would not have ends which seemed to
be causing me issues earlier you were
kind of shape that didn't have ends a
circle doesn't have ends right now
remember I asked you before this is is
it possible right what's the minimum
number we said on the fact that 4 is
definitely sort of a baseline but we see
we needed more and 4 because if you want
to create a circle and I've got coins in
front of you right now can you do this
I'm going to do my best to try an AB
souville these things round so let's say
let's take these guys let's sort of
rotate them around like this oops sorry
I missed
let's put these guys over here this is
not a circle yet but it's getting there
isn't it what can I do I want this guy
to attach over here how's that look does
that look good it's the same shape as
before it's the same chain I just kind
of speeding it I'm just rotating it
around yeah okay what have I got it's
just going to work let me try
I'll see will I get the shape that I
want how is that what do you think
whoops sorry does it have the
characteristics I need it it's got the
chain sort of thing that we saw was
working it's just the end except have a
look at what the ends are where are the
ends they used to be here
this is one of them right and then what
it joins up to is this guy that's what
it joined up to so what I've done is
I've created a loop that goes all the
way around you have a look let me get
rid of that orange circle kids saw it in
the way does everything actually satisfy
the condition it works right so is this
is this mathematics that's not a not a
rhetorical question is expect Mattox
what what make sure I've deleted in math
class so that makes a mathematic can we
qualify that statement because this is
not like any other kind of mathematics
you've done right this is where we
distinguish between exercises and
problems exercises are things you know
how to do you get taught steps you
replicate them and when you see another
exercise you I know exactly what to do
here a problem is unfamiliar by its
nature but you can still fiddle with it
and you can see it's a fact many of you
got very very close to getting a
solution it was just for the sake of
time but I was like well okay let me
show you how to do this okay